Missile maintenance in the United States Air
Force. I was a staff sergeant. A lot of other
schools are just giving you a piece of paper
for your degree. Hillsdale, you're actually
getting an education that you can use. Core
curriculum is tough. Right now, I'm in the
Western Heritage and the Constitution 101
course. And so, we're learning about the philosophy
of the Greeks and what is politics. Every
student has to go through those and it gives
you a good liberal arts education, a good
grounding in our heritage here. The relationship
with professors here is really good. They're
small classes so you get to know the professors.
The professors know you. If you're struggling
in class, they want you to go to their office
on their office hours and talk to them and
discuss the concepts, and they're not just
there during classroom hours. They're there
all the time.
The vibe at Hillsdale is great. You always
see students out in the quad, talking with
each other and discussing what's been going
on in class. And there's always a lot of back
and forth debate, I guess I would say, about
the different concepts they learned. But it's
very relaxed and intense at the same time.
Someone who's in the military, I think they
should really look into Hillsdale. They don't
accept the GI bill here, but they still pay
for everything. They give you a veteran's
scholarship and so you don't have to worry
about the cost. They give you room and board
and meal plan. It is a small school so you
don't transition from the military into this
large school that no one really cares about
you. Here, you have a smaller school where
everyone does care.